The most important thing
you have to remember,
is that every time you transfer data,
no matter how small,
the radio could stay powered up
for nearly half a minute.
So every decision you make,
should be based
on minimizing the number of times
that this happens.
But of course there's a balance here.
You want to download all the data
a user is likely to need
for the current section,
in a single burst,
over a single connection
at full capacity.
But of course, you don't just want
to pull down everything
wasting battery power and bandwidth
downloading data that's
never going to be used.
Now I could go on for hours on this topic,
but Dan's getting impatient,
and you can learn the details
on how to implement
each of these best practices,
including pre-fetching,
batching, and bundling,
burying you rupdate frequency,
and minimizing your payloads,
by watching the series
of Dev Lite videos
or reading the developer guides
linked to in the instructor notes below.
Now before I leave it to Dan
to show you how to implement
a sync adapter for Sunshine
that takes advantage
of a lot of the best practices
I just described,
let's consider what the
best practice would be
if you were building something
like a news reader app.
How much data should you download
when the app is first started?
Just the front page of headlines?
All the stories and images
linked to from that front page?
Every story available,
but none of the images?
Or every story and every image
currently available?